growing up it allows being gay you go to
her and my father put my arm to make me
tell me this is what it feels for five
seconds imagine eternity action we can
all relate to someone who is coming from
a small town who is not able to be
himself
I play Zane he helps Rafi discover a new
way to live his life
you're not afraid people will find out
of course I'm scared that's why I'm
going to America I'm gonna be a
Hollywood star Rafiq he needs to leave
the Middle East he is not safe because
of his sexual orientation and he needs
to seek asylum so many people across the
world have struggled so much to find a
place where they can be themselves and
more than that to like know that they
can be loved you know when it comes to
artists rights in Syria they are
persecuted especially when they approach
any freedom issues and I believe that
this project comes as a response this is
the first show about LGBTQ rights in
Syria and it opens a new conversation
it's very important for us to give this
story justice so that everyone who sees
it will be very moved in
we've changed
[Music]
you
[Music]
you